[Music]
what is up welcome back to my channel
this week i want to show you a guy he's
called ali
i met him when he was 18 years old he
joined my property investors academy
with his dad's blessing
and over the last couple of years he's
gone on to do 15 property deals
but not only that he's become a rich
wise
knowledgeable investor and i think
you're going to be really impressed by
his knowledge and what he's done so ali
welcome to windows on a wednesday
thank you so so much for having me
samuel you keep messaging me on
instagram
every time you do a deal you're like
this is a deal just a deal i wanted to
kind of show you the whole
i mean i wanted to kind of keep you
updated and kind of show you that you
know i'm really doing in
you know all thanks to you i mean the
sort of the practical the theory side is
purely based on the academy and it's
been
you know absolutely you know best thing
i've ever done to be honest i'll
highly highly recommend it awesome um
i'll tell you the story actually i mean
i came to the uh crash course in
december 2019. you were literally 18.
i was 18 years old yeah i was 18 years
old came to the crash course december
2019 with my father
um i booked onto the crash course a
couple days before i you know told my
dad said dad
you know i've booked you on there's no
show fee so i guess you're coming to be
honest with you he looked at me and he
said
sounds good yeah so came when they came
to the crash course
absolutely amazing you know the amount
of people there you know
the whole sort of environment that you
know the knowledge given you know the
atmosphere
everything it was a you know i've never
been to a certain event like that before
it was it was my first time
what did your dad think of the of the
event he loved it as well yeah they got
so close together on that time so did
you
were you kind of coming were you
thinking like this better be good
because i'm 18 i've dragged my dad along
if it's so i knew it would be good no no
i knew it was okay
i actually knew it would be good how did
you know it would be good i mean the
information you applied on the video
i mean i i kind of did it without
hesitation because i mean you said
just you know sign up and come to the
you know you're doing a free play
yeah why not i'm watching the
gentleman's videos and if i could come
and see him
and see him there and it cost me nothing
it's in london i live in london
why not okay she came along so what
actually happened like what did you
learn on the crash course what happened
okay so crash course um i mean in terms
of learning side
you you the whole sort of understanding
about the return on investment i mean
obviously i knew i knew these things
beforehand but the actual
you know really truly understanding how
money can actually be made through
property
in a lot greater scale because you know
there's different ways people look at
and they say you know it's just buying a
property renting it out and they look at
yield and they look at so on and so
forth
but really understanding you know return
on your investment understanding a
growth of you know
business ways for maybe making the deal
sourcing you know rent to rent these
things you know really open up and
actually understanding
how it can be done and you know what
steps i need to take to do it
and you know i kind of understood the
whole knowledge and i thought to myself
well
this is the best thing ever you know if
i want to grow a company if i want to
grow a business and
you know this this guy's helping out and
he's given all this information he's
providing it all when
he's given an opportunity to join an
academy i told my dad well dad
i know it's a lot of money can i please
join the academy
you know my dad said okay well you
really want to do that you know
he knows i did i didn't want to do it i
told him you know i'll sell certain
things you know i'll give a good
what does that mean what do you have i
saw my downhill race bike i was a down
eraser for a little bit of time it was
you know are you still a downhill race
i sold the bike so you
had to give that up i had to give that
up completely how much how much did you
get for the bike
uh i've got about three and a half
thousand pound for the ball oh nice yeah
and then you bought it for a lot more so
it's quite a heavy hit on
okay my mum a serious stink it was a big
thing your dad put money in and they'll
put money in you came together pulled up
together yeah what do you was you again
was your dad thinking like
this better work well i told my dad um
this is where i told him was like dad
i'll pay you from the money i make which
i'll make from property
right and you know he thought to himself
well
it can be done because i'm sitting there
with him and i'm seeing how it's being
done
and he knows me and and he knows that i
will truly do
what i really really would tell him that
you know have you made the money back i
have made the money back
again and again and again and again and
again yeah right okay
so so let's talk about that then so you
go through the academy now you
are smart you're a smart guy and even
though you're young because sometimes
people think if you're young you might
struggle with property but actually
being being 18 sometimes you're you're
academically quite smart
you might not have the experience in
property but you whisk through the
training you've got to do it in a few
months
i even missed out on a holiday to come
to the training for my family when i
hold their mouth we went on a holiday i
said
no no i've got academy trading i'm going
to go to it and try to get it all done
quickly which means i didn't know
chronovost was coming and if i hadn't
enough
pressured myself to get it all done
quickly quickly quickly quickly quickly
yeah i would have probably missed it and
it would have hit the lockdown period so
i'm very
glad that i did i think it was only the
accelerated coaching and mentoring
program
yeah that you missed which are coming
back to you now i'll come back which is
great
so okay so you get through the training
what was the academy like
okay okay it was amazing amazing just
the whole
the whole time from waking up in the
morning knowing you know you come into
an amazing place with amazing
knowledgeable people with the
atmosphere in the environment you know
you come in and it's
hard hard you know a couple days of pure
information you know you get the book
you sit down you truly it's purely all
you know it's kind of theory and there
is practical stuff inside as well you
know there's times where you know they
get sent out to you know
get the deals yourself and you know it
truly is
you know every single thing that you
think you you need you'll have it
yeah there's not a single thing that you
won't have by going to the academy in
terms of the actual
theory side the understanding how it's
done yeah in terms of actually
understanding how to grow the business
how to make money from your company
how you need to do it all the compliance
stages that you need to do it all is
kind of given to you
there and it really just up to you to
kind of listen and do it i mean there's
so many other people in the room so you
know you can always say you know how
come everyone else doesn't get
successful but it's just to implement
what's been said to be honest with you
because it's all
given to you yeah and that at that
extent and the academy you mentioned two
days
yep because normally a training program
is two days
but then you you go on lots and lots of
different training programs and yourself
mentoring and everything like that
so okay so you go through the training
walk me through your
first deal okay um i'll talk you from my
first deal
from my main investor and i'll get to
how i got to if you if you want to get
to that stage so
um after i went to the academy after i i
went to the crash course
i set off my own company um i set my
company up and uh
you know i made the website i put a
little bit of money in in the business
i thought to myself well you know i've
made a promise to my father this is what
i'm going to be doing this i'm going to
be paying off so
i'm going to fill out to do that um i
did kind of you know do a little bit of
code deal sourcing and then did a little
information understanding myself
and then a little bit further down they
got to the state of around coronavirus
time
where one of my main deals had actually
fallen through at that time and it was
kind of a bit
at the time where i thought okay because
of this lockdown thing
property may be taking a little bit of a
stop obviously i was watching the videos
and you know things were saying
otherwise but
to myself i got kind of dragged into
forex and trading
where you know i worked for actually a
company to do trading for a couple bit
for a little bit of time
and afterwards uh the actual owner of
the company this year he put me in and
he said
i know you've been doing property i know
you've tried to set up a property
business and this was all for me
basically talking about what i was doing
beforehand to him and he said well what
i want to do is i want to make some
money from property
and i know you've had training and he
literally said i know you've gone to
gone and done the training i know you've
experienced from this stuff
so would you want to help me out with
this and do you want to work together to
do this
of course yes and you know what can i
just stop you right there though because
that's really important number one when
you invest in yourself
yes then people want to invest in
definitely 100 percent
there's no i would have never been given
this opportunity if i hadn't joined an
academy and i'm saying necessarily have
to join
an academy twos but one thousand percent
it's the fact that they know what this
guy has the knowledge
i don't have that knowledge or whatever
that knowledge is so
and it's not rookie it's not knowledge
picked up from bits and bobs and
a youtube video here and a mentor here
and a person and and
dave the pub and it's like no i've got
the
straightforward abc xyz
yeah so you had the knowledge you had
the reputation to be able to say i've
got the knowledge
you were worried that's funny that is
because you're on the academy and
everything and then we went to lockdown
i was saying on youtube
yeah i was doing financial freedom
challenges from my house and lots yes
and you were like i'll tell you the
reason being to it because i wasn't very
much of a
sort of online thing i tried to do
advertising on facebook and stuff i i
sat down and tried yeah
but for me it just did i understand i
just thought was it when they closed
down the property market it was
you just thought forget this i thought
to myself well okay um
oil's falling the currencies commodities
are fulfilling there's bitcoin i thought
there's a lot of money to be made
and everyone talked about you know
they're waiting for this time i had the
bill of money saved up as well
you know i had money to owe to my father
as well about time but i thought to
myself well
i could put a little bit of money in
there which was a mistake on my behalf
to my father
i put a little bit of money on on the
trading side and how did it go it didn't
go very well in terms of the oil market
i didn't make money on everything else
but
it was a heavy hit on on when right and
the oil fell but you wanted to you
wanted to
you were just the the whole property
market was locked down yeah so you
thought you'd donate a little bit i put
on a pause
i thought the guy who who was head of
the
forex company was like actually i want
to do a property yeah because i had
i'd explained in the process before i
had obviously talked to him and we have
a very good relationship and
and you know i told them it's as easy as
this to make money you know you just
you know that you can buy a house like
that you know you just cost this
everything it's the build process
and if you find the right house you can
sell it from for more yeah it's all
about adding the value to the property
for example in terms of actually the
flipping side
and you know he understood what i was
trying to say he understood the whole
process and he answered that very well
this gentleman is a very very smart and
very very successful businessman himself
you know more than other ones close but
a couple hundred million
just for himself and his position and he
he said to me ali
i want to do this i now need you to if
you're interested in helping me out
go and find out where's the best area
for me to invest that will give me the
most
so you know it took me you know a couple
weeks to research that area that area
that i would find my patch which is
obviously what you did teach at that
time as well so
i looked at how much the property
markets fall in that area how much it's
risen
altogether how much it does rise in that
area so a lot of research into finding
deciding to my area
where's the best place for us to invest
online can you reveal what what your
patch is yep micro university
sheffield rover and doncaster sheffield
rotherham doncaster
why did you choose that patch so i chose
that patch and basis of okay there's one
thing this is from the academy as well
and
i'll give it a bit so it's in terms of
ratio wise as well which was the biggest
factor for me
in terms of houses on the market and how
many houses on the market have been sold
so you know that every house put the
market about three or four houses get
sold
yeah and sheffield and doncaster one of
the best ratios from my side you know
a house will come it will go and that
wasn't even during the whole
sort of property sort of boom and
everything it was very very good at that
time
you know it had fallen a decent amount
it was sort of everything had been
placed
and we could see good good good years of
growth and we knew that you know we
could make good money from that area we
knew that
there was train lines coming you know we
did all of our you know i did all of my
research and to know really really
that this place could give a really
really good boom and could make you know
that's a brilliant point and to get that
especially if you're looking at flipping
or brr like you've done
yeah but it is you just have to look how
many houses are for sale in the whole of
sheffield
include houses sold and they're not
include houses sold and you can see the
rights you can see
exactly exactly and if it says if it
says there's a thousand houses for sale
oh and including houses for sold there's
a thousand and fifty you think oh houses
aren't selling very well there yeah
if it says including houses that have
sold there's three thousand yeah
well well that means that there aren't
anything and then they're all subject to
contract in the past sort of five or six
months so you know to yourself well
these houses are going and they're
growing well if you get a good house in
the market that's
good location exactly what the buyers
are looking for with a good either
return or a good you know appealing to a
first-time buyer
there'll be no problem to sell a house
where was the first deal was it in
rotherham sheffield
first i was in don costa tell me the
figure so uh first of all it was bought
for 39.995
13995 why did you buy that price avoid
stamp duty
right it was a very good relationship
with the estate agent i've actually
bought three properties from that
station
yeah three properties from that station
right uh and i first negotiated and told
them listen i know and this is something
that i know from you i didn't
know myself that you know if you could
give enough right 39.995 you'd avoid
stamp duty and
you know every literally everything i've
learned it
from the academy training and from you
and for my own sort of knowledge and
putting it in from the property side so
i bought it for 39.95 i gave him 1005
pounds in cash
to the prior so it was about forty one
thousand pounds we'd estimated the end
value sale at that time i've
estimated about sixty nine thousand to
about seventy thousand pounds in terms
of the flip sale
i told them that you're gonna get you're
gonna get anywhere between the 65 figure
to around about the 74 figure
and you know houses were selling from
around about that price in that area we
came up there with my investor you know
i
we had many days of houses booked you
know i would book 10 houses 10 houses 10
houses we kept going kept coming back
yeah
to see to get good feel we saw this one
house it was very very well priced and
it's weird because for an investor like
that when they look at households 40 000
they just see it as
almost nothing now i know that sounds
strange but they said what's the worst
that could happen okay you know
forty thousand pound for a property yeah
it's meant to make money it's a business
they're looking no stam duty no stamp
set so he bought it for 39 and a five
yeah has he sold it now
he's it's selling now it's at this
moment in time selling we've gone off
throughout the property
oh i'll get to the sale of the reason of
why more than double
okay and i'll tell you what however we
did spend a little bit of more money how
much has been on it so i'll get to that
stage now in a second so
the main thing is we looked at it in
terms of a business point of view we
looked and said we're going to drop
about a million pounds on this we're
going to buy a million pounds off of
property
not counting obviously the materials and
all the costs but we wanted to put a
million other property
and looking as a point of business
approach now at this point of time the
investor also wanted to kind of set up
their own
sort of construction company as well
which is if you know how that sort of
thing goes it's not the easiest thing
and
you can get kind of stung and you know
we did come across challenges at the
beginning as well
we had one sort of build team that kind
of messed around and we lost a little
bit of money in terms of the labor cost
and
and the materials and a little bit of
that so the sort of build cost came
around about
24 000 pounds 25 000 pounds uh in terms
of the actual labor cost which we'd
estimated to be a lot less but
a little bit of that is because of labor
cost from something separate and we're
looking at the point of the business
point of view where
you know we even thought we're going to
make losses on the first one or two
properties
and as a business you know standpoint we
didn't we were making profit on the
first house
yeah absolutely like almost 20 grand on
that first house yeah which is not bad
at all not bad at all so we spent about
twenty four thousand
thinking for about eight to five hundred
best best possible things
we could that's awesome so that was the
first one first property now this guy
this wealthy guy that was like you're
trained well you're knowledgeable
i want you to find me deals how many
properties have you sold him over the
last
18 months or so 15 properties 15 15.
just to him
just to him and it's him and his
business partner now we we
um sort of transfer the properties into
different company names we have one
company that holds 10 properties
another company that holds another 10
and and so on and so forth are you
full-time in property full-time so your
full-time property
in my office every day so this guy how
much does he pay you so i get a flat
rate of no matter what if i don't get a
deal to him i get 1.3 k and that's on
flatness now every single key that i
hand to him
i get around about 2.2 you know per key
that i hand him and i physically have to
give him the key
and he has to put it in his drawer and
he told me as soon as i get the key in
my draw you get paid so just from this
guy how much do you reckon he's giving
you in total how much have you made from
this one guy i've made i've
disclosed well you can calculate the
figures was about 40 grand okay cool
so you've made a d i mean not bad not
bad i mean it doesn't actually matter
how much
i never actually fall even be making
money i went into it as purely the
learning process to it right
the money is obviously you know it
sounds it's a huge benefit to it but you
know the whole
point is i've got the theory from you
and now it's time to actually get the
practical side
and i've done the a to z to everything
buying the house finding solicitors i
had
i've gone for a process to multiple
solicitors i went to one solicitor
found out they were slow they weren't
doing good position to another solicitor
work got good relationship with another
solicitor
worked on with them you know everything
was purely you know growing up this
business from from the bottom up to yeah
well yeah you've had the you've learned
how to do it
you didn't have the capital so you
teamed up with somebody who's paid
you a retainer plus commissions yep you
made a decent amount about 40 grand from
him and on top of that you've been
learning how to how to grow
a business from the ground up the actual
practical
combined with the theory from the
academy i think it's incredible so
as any of the deals have any of them
lost money no
they've all made money or making money
talk me through some of the some of the
i can talk to you one by one each one of
the properties if you want something
well i mean it could take a long time
but if you think it depends on how long
we have so so first one number
i'm not sure if i can say the house name
or number is that something that we
could yeah
as long as you're comfortable if it's
sold i probably wouldn't if it hasn't
like
i usually i usually don't put addresses
out there but if it's sold
then it's fine it's a contract to the
sell side whatever you're comfortable
with whatever you're comfortable with
number 105 and
number 105 stability go on taught me
through the figures so that was the
first 40 thousand pound house and we've
got another one this one was in uh rob
room in dillington i'm not sure if you
know where dinnington is in the
rotherham area no it's a little bit so
we've got
doncaster rotherham and dinnington's
around about here-ish yeah so dinnington
was a great area we came in
there was this all gentleman guy you
know he said he'd got an offer about 65
and he got officer 64.
i came in with the investor and i said
we're serious buyers cash you know
it really does help having a good push
behind you in terms of
being able to deliver on what you say
being able to say i'll buy it you know
the first house that we went to you know
the stage and looked at me and said yes
we're buying it we'll buy cash buy in 20
something days
clicked on me and said okay we'll see
what you do and since then i've
delivered to him and we've got another
two or three houses
because of that reason and again i've
got a list here with all the properties
that you that you've done yeah
i've given you a couple of the and um
and you and you've been and you've been
sending me videos i've been telling you
pretty much every time i mean i thought
to myself well everyone else is sending
him and
are they really doing or how's it going
well i'm really doing it it doesn't help
it doesn't hurt to just show you a
little bit of what's really going on
because yeah it is all thanks to you and
i really didn't want to tell you that
thank you very much samuel i'm doing it
this is because of these reasons
so what's the biggest learning points
that you've made biggest learning points
okay a lot of things
um you have to find the right people
most important thing
right connections because when you're on
the phone with somebody else and you're
speaking to them
it's purely on basis of how you deliver
to them you know if you say i'm going to
get that email out to you
i'm going to do that to you i'm going to
make sure we purchase that property i'm
going to complete the next amount of
days
it is delivering on what you say to them
is purely basis of
how well you do it how sort of on point
you are with them you know you have to
basically
sort of i don't know how to say it
basically um so
be the first person there all the time
just be in front of their eyes and make
sure that they
the estate agents know you i mean i've
given hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of calls to estate agents
houses that i know myself i'm not gonna
make money on
that i know myself this isn't something
good i'm still gonna give them the call
and say
tell me about the property why because
it's just talking to them it's them here
and saying hi it's ally calling again oh
hey ellie and
i've called them hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of times i mean it's purely
the basis of knowing that
this guy is definitely buying he's he's
first always first always first always
they say
the house has just come on the market
yes i know it's coming to market that's
why i'm here i'm the first one
to get it because it's on them so your
houses that you're finding then you
generally i mean looking at the list you
generally find stuff you're buying stuff
for like
really cheap yep so the budget that we
had was 150 000 at first we did zero to
100 and then as soon as the property
market kind of boomed up
we kind of increased 150. so the whole
point was we wanted to get around about
30 properties in the year
we haven't hit that target because it's
been very tough and finding houses are
actually
making a lot of money and the
competition comes on and people keep
building on top and
it's got to the stage now um so you know
we haven't hear our target but we've
done very very good so far
talk to me about the refurb because when
you're doing the deal like you're doing
there's three costs that matter you know
this what are the three costs so the
purchase price
the solve the you know purchase purchase
costs including all the legal fees and
yeah
and everything then you've got your
legal legal then you've got your build
cost
yeah because including your labor your
material and everything and then you've
got your end value seller correct so
those are the three figures that matter
now you're you're finding your houses
and getting them cheap from estate
agents is that right are they all coming
from agents every single one
are they on market or off market i mean
i've got
four of one three of them were off
market four of them
four of them were off market and then
the rest were on market however
a couple of them were auction properties
as well however i've had times where
i've actually pulled houses out of
people's hands you know i've come and
said i've got another ground on top
this is my situation to make sure that
it's go to then to go get it and i've
pulled out houses from
multiple people's hands which you may
think is you know why would somebody do
that but
i've done that before what do you mean
what do you mean i mean so for example
a house number 13 phrase the road this
house was on the property on the market
for i think it was 110.
yeah yeah it was an auction property and
i called them and said they said we've
had an offer you know they're getting
their legal
funds sorted they're definitely
interested in buying it and they're
doing everything to pay the 6
300 pound auction fee i said to them
they're not on the same level of what
i'm going to do i'm going to pay that
right now and we'll get this property
go call them right now i paid for that
straight on then 600 on their account
hustle's on my hand there that guy's too
slow to kind of act on that behalf it's
all about the basis of
doing it fast and making sure you're the
first one there you know you can beat
your sort of competition in terms of
actually getting the property and
getting the house and the great thing
about you being a deal saucer with one
we've
been working with this one company is
that they trust you implicitly trust me
everything and also you
trust them you know that the money's
there yeah so you can just say to the
agent
i'm buying this right now right
whereas if you were trying to package it
and pass it on to an investor you didn't
know existed yet yeah it's a whole
different story
which was a little bit of the stage at
the beginning because that was yeah a
little bit
and it was a little bit trickier it
obviously can be done and it was done
at that stage but having having somebody
you know having the actual you know i've
heard you say before what comes first
the investor the deal it's definitely
the investor because when you have the
actual money there to act and
truly say we're buying it and we're
buying it now yeah and
you know there's no changing there's no
funny business changing the name there
there's no doing anything like that it's
purely what i'm saying to you is what it
is yes it changes everything basically
yeah in terms of power chain
power team talk to me about who needs to
be in your team okay so
okay so you need a very very good
solicitor yeah solicitor that you can
get hold of very easily you need that
understands you understands where the
funds come from understands
how you get your funds now in this case
this company you know had a lot of funds
under the saving points but they also
had business sales that would kind of do
for the funds so
on the basis of how the business would
do it would you know you would make
i'm going to say how much but it would
make the money and then i could kind of
top this
list and say this is where the funds are
coming from this is how we will fund it
you know we will chat to you around
about 20 000 pounds as it goes on you
know a couple times a month
just so you have you know the money to
kind of pay for the properties after
solicitors you need a very good
tax advisor or a good you know lawyer
this is what i found to be very very
good
now you need these two to work very very
closely together you need the tax
advisor you know to came back your stamp
duty to you know
claiming back all these sort of things
to work very closely with your solicitor
as well
yeah not only that then you need to go
for your build team now you need a good
you need all around everything now the
way i can say about the build team is
him himself has tried to make his own
construction team in his own build team
so what i've been kind of done too is
i've been the one that's sort of
tried to find the people calling this
guy calling that guy trying to find
you know plasterboards you know trying
to find the skimmers trying to find
plumbers
trying to get all these sort of things
and these things take time and they're
very very
hard to do you know you get builders
that come and you get people that mess
around and especially in terms of when
you try to set up the business for
yourself
it's different to paying your contractor
and saying come and do it how much
you're going to cost
but that's that wasn't our strategy you
know we want to make our own company
so what happens you complete on a house
yep you go you want to get the house
done
beautifully it's a dump what what are
the steps okay so
every single house i know how much it
will cost and we
because we pay for our own labors we pay
for our materials and we ship our
materials from elsewhere and we get it
under any any other price that i know
other people can't compare to
our costs for the refurbs are
considerably lower to anyone else
for somebody let's say we'll cost them
50 000 it'll cost us only 20 000.
and that's the reality and that really
is truly based on what it is
once you know you bring once once we
negotiate the property we get the house
i try to get the builders in some time
in the middle
but usually it doesn't actually matter
when we get the builders in
because we've seen the house ourselves
we know how it looks like
we don't even have to know a lot of
things to it now a lot of people
spend time on basis of getting that done
bringing over structural surveys getting
everything done but our build team can
do all of that
you know they just know we're coming in
we're taking it back to brick and we're
building off
as long as there's no sort of structural
damage you know there's no sort of
sitting there's there's no you know it
doesn't need any under floor planning
doesn't mean anything like that
they should be good in terms of what to
do with the property and get to get it
done
so they come in they completely do
everything out to it they strip it all
out
they then get to the process of the
building side now we do a little bit of
checks as it goes on now the main person
that checks is
the investor's very hands-on so he
drives there twice a week just to see
how the building is
and he's the one obviously that pays the
the builders themselves so he's very
sort of keen on understanding how the
process is going with them um
do you project manager at all i do
project manager builders i project
manage in terms of
where they come who to come the
employees that come and these employees
that we pay for we pay them in terms of
we bring them in we put them under 100
pounds first about 80 pounds we pay them
then 100 pounds then 150 we go master
medium and you know they kind of grow
one as it is and the main thing is
we put many many you know as in terms of
the company setting up
we get a couple of the people that are
about 80 80 80 80 80 pounds
a lot of people 100 100 100 pounds and
these people are more experienced and
then we've got 150 151 5150 and the
whole point is to keep
their experience kind of passing down
and giving a sort of cycle
to get the cheapest sort of labor cost
that we can and that is a strange
example that is
the main way that we we do it you know
we want to get the cheapest sort of
labor costs in
so you've got a really nice system with
the build costs yeah
what would your advice be to somebody
that's watching this that wants to do a
little flip but they're saying i haven't
got or
i can't buy the materials direct i
haven't got all the tape so there's a
lot of
websites and stuff that you can get the
materials directly it's just you know
calling any builder
obviously do you do your research on you
know you can look on facebook and see
what type of builders
people advertise themselves you know
we've got you know
it is hard i'm not saying it is very
hard we have had obviously situation
where one of our builders
you know we had a builder in a house for
about a month and a bit and they were
purely messing around we lost money on
the labor cost but that was an
experience on our behalf of
how we had to actually manage these
people you know they were just
they were staying in hotels then they
were coming in the property we had to
pay for the hotels we had to pay for the
labor
there were then we got to a point where
we've got so many houses now you're
gonna stay in this property
right i said we need the car we have to
buy them the car we have to buy them the
materials they need to empty out the
rubbish or the of the you know they need
to empty everything we said it'll be
cheaper for us if we put in the vans if
we take them and offload them ourselves
we did all the process to find out what
we need to do then we said okay nope
we're going to get the skips instead you
know it's going to cost us x amount for
skips
and all to find the cheapest skip you
know people give you farming japan for a
pro
400 pound for a quote and it's just a
time consuming part of understanding who
is the guy
that will give you the cheapest skip
yeah best things ever you're not even
like looking particularly for more
investors i know you haven't got
now yep an exclusivity agreement with
your guy
but a lot of people are like desperately
looking for more investors
but you're really picky about who you
work with no yeah i don't want to choose
i mean this investor i mean the way i
want to have an investor i mean if i do
go for the push of getting some after is
it's very personal yeah it's very one to
one is having dinners with them having
meetings with them all the time and it's
not purely
you don't see the investor you give them
the deal when you pay them it's purely
of
what are you looking for how do you want
it to be done and i've never disclosed
anything to that investor because there
was no agreement like that
so it's come say this house is coming
now let's go see it tomorrow all right
this is going to go we're going to see
it now can we see it no
send the builder off i can call the
builder and say builder what's your
property now what's your long-term goal
early because
for 20 years old you've done remarkably
well you met you're making very good
money
your money is uncapped you've got
extremely good knowledge
of an industry that's very lucrative
what's your long-term goals my long-term
goals in terms of i want to set up my
own company
and i really do want to set it off and
make it the biggest best possible
company that i can
i want to set off in terms of the deal
sourcing side as well i want to have a
team
for me with good investors and multiple
strategies you know i want to
kind of work with investors directly and
these investors are high high-level
high-class investors
that they will sit with will understand
what they're looking to get i want to
kind of
go grow this business out myself in
terms of
really really becoming the best possible
deal source out there
so you do want to grow the deals
but you want to just grow it very slowly
we're working with the right people very
slowly
there's no rush to it quality quality it
really is quality
and for me it really has to be the right
investor do you want to build your own
portfolio as well
definitely definitely right definitely i
do have the money to buy a house myself
at the moment but that's not my goal at
the moment my goal is how much money you
have in the bank
close that um
[Music]
50 grand and and that's come from deal
sourcing still sourcing and
you know money coming in from what about
what about why haven't you got a car yet
i've never needed one to be honest with
you how are you how are you finding
these deals without driving okay so the
investor drives me i grew up with the
investor
oh yeah yeah oh so you finally come
three hours in the morning at seven
o'clock jump in the car at seven o'clock
head through so you find that you do the
work you do the ground work and then you
say to the investor come on let's go
look at it together i mean the investor
loves themselves to come obviously i
mean
it's a good day out right they go and
check up on the builders as well you
know we go on look at a couple of houses
we drive around we go have
lunch we go to fish and chips we go get
it so it's a great sort of
feeling and great sort of you've kind of
made your own thing
out yes you know which is great to see
because you know on the academy
one of the things you'll probably be
able to vouch for is we don't create
gingerbread men where everybody's the
same yes we give everyone the tools
and then they go and make their own yeah
craftsmanship you know
and that's what you've done really
remarkably well i mean i will buy a car
i can
i can get a card thing is my dad says
this is my this is my fault that i don't
get a car and people may look and say
well that's this is stupid what is this
guy saying but
i want to get a nice car and the nice
car that i want to get is all my money
which is very stupid to do that and you
know as much of invest that money
i don't want to drive a bad car because
there's no need to it there's no need
for it so
i'm comfortable where i am with have you
got a license i do have license
i have the driven yeah i've got a
license only a couple months ago
actually so all right
you're going to crash the car so many
times anyway yeah
you know but all right dude seriously
inspirational
you know what would be your key pieces
of advice
to somebody watching this okay piece of
advice okay so you definitely need to
get the
theory side of it so i thank you so much
for the various side
you know you need to get there's just a
couple pieces to it just the theory
then the practical yeah i've had the
theory from you very very grateful
practical from them very very grateful
and putting these things together is
a to z of everything to get in the
actual sort of setting up
you need good relationship with the
agents firstly yeah definitely a good
relationship
need to be talking in a truthful manner
you know you shouldn't be calling and
say we're buying and you know when
you're not actually buying because
this thing damages sort of other
investors like even
me calling they're saying that we've had
an offer forward and i said
me and you both know that offer is
probably from and i've used this word
before it's probably from another deal
source that isn't ready
are they really as ready as us and then
they they come back and say we'll go
talk to the vendor and then we'll show
you a position
i give them information of all the
companies we have every single house
that we have in our companies
you know all of our proof of funds and
we try to come out in the best possible
strategy
to get these properties and for people
that are looking best thing for them to
do is kind of
go truthfully forward you know you need
to kind of have a good relationship with
them
you have to call them all the time you
need to don't bother them with your
calls obviously just
calling them you know obviously i don't
think that really matters in terms of
bothering them with the calls but
you just need to kind of you don't mind
bothering people i know that i don't
mind i mean
it's business i mean they're they're
getting paid to be there i'm yeah
i'm working yeah you know it's the
relationship you're building with them
i'm not bothered from
calling them 100 times and saying hey
hey what you have what you have what you
have what you have
they're going to pick up the phone
because it's a company phone so they're
going to pick up when they're gone
so true and i think often a lot of
people are scared to call an agent
because they feel like they're bothering
them they're people they're people but
they're also as you said they're there
to work they're there to work
exact same thing what does your dad
think of what you've done okay
uh good and it sounds strange but
he's not he thinks i should be further
than when i where i am
even though i've you know i have
succeeded in many many ways but he
thinks you know i probably should have
had my own company set up i should have
done done those things and
i keep telling him dad i can you know
i'm doing it myself i'm doing myself
reasons well if you could do it yourself
then why haven't you serving companies
it's not like that i'm working here i'm
getting my experience yeah because
you've got enough money to go and buy
your own property yep
you know and do a flip yourself yeah and
start growing your own
yeah but you're just loving making money
learning loads yeah
you know the funny thing is if i go to
make my own property and do the flip
myself it kind of
pushes me away from all the potential
future that i have over there
at this point in time yeah i mean not
everyone can be you know in that
position of where i am over there and
and this thing i see is a sort of long
trajectory you know we haven't kind of
completed a lot of
you know the sales so as soon as all of
these get pushed through
i can then come back and take an
investor well i've made you a couple
hundred thousand pounds you know you can
see that
i now kind of want to move away or i
kind of want to stay how can we go about
from then on
yeah that's the process yeah you're
playing at the long game and you're also
you know you're 100 player like after
you've done the academy events
you came back you were crewing yes we're
in the samuel league
i was t-shirt of course because the
people around and i wanted to
let the people know i mean i told people
guys this is
amazing you know i would i loved koon i
love you know
at that time the crews you know they
were staying in the hotels it was the
people around and a couple of the other
people that were good
were saying i'm crewing too and i i'm on
a cruise i want to be part of it too
yeah you know a couple of people on the
academy were crewing and i thought
it's their crew and it's all about the
back side and i thought i have time on
my hands at that time and
yeah definitely put it there as well so
the experience of actually coming there
to the academy was amazing what is your
strongest reason
for wanting to do all this strongest
reason now i know this is the why that
we'll get to in terms of the actual um
accelerated mentor and all these things
now for me my why is
i don't know the strongest reason should
be it's basically just i want to have a
really really well established company
and just have
but why why why i don't
many reasons for it i haven't got the
specific answer and i've thought about
this myself so many times
you must know exactly i should why do
you want a big company i want to just
just the sort of the the not the freedom
but the
the sort of just i like the feeling of
being part of
big things and you know being with the
big people and
actually you know you know delivering
and succeeding and they look and they
can look at you and say well this 20
year old has
done so many things and i like that sort
of feeling i like being part
of it right with those people and for
that reason i want to kind of grow the
biggest company
i want to kind of show everyone that i
can do it and it really is as
easy as i would do it and i can do it
and you know your family are in business
and stuff yeah what's their background
what's your father has a uh
is a software architecture's it company
um he's done very well for himself he's
you know he's he's born born and bred in
iran yep you were born in iran i was
wondering i moved here
when i was very young yeah so my father
actually moved there with nothing he
said of his own company he's done very
very well and
you know for me i've always said to him
why don't you give me some money i'll
invest it for you
you could be my investor and all sorts
of things i already invested in you just
do the academy yeah he's saying i've
already
said that he said i've already wrestled
in the academy he's but his his point of
view
is is always business he invests his
money in his business
and he says the same thing to me he says
any money you get you invest in your
business and that's the easiest and best
way to make money is he glad that he
invested in you on the academy
yes he think that was a good decision
well that's good to hear definitely what
would you say to somebody that was
thinking of coming to a crash course
why are you kid of course why not i mean
why not truly why not it doesn't take
long
there is easy to come it's free so
definitely come and it's
unbelievable it really is unbelievable
it's the best bottle and i couldn't be
thankful enough to really
get in all this theory deciding and
getting all this this knowledge that
i've been given it really is
unbelievable i mean just it's the whole
point of getting yourself into that
mindset of really thinking
you know there's people around me that's
doing it and if you really want to
succeed you can't just be the guy hidden
around that it doesn't
doesn't do things very well and and
doesn't deliver and doesn't wake up in
the morning and
doesn't spend long days in the office
and to really do it you just got put
your time you just got
put hard working that's great work is
just coming in well dude mad respect for
me in the team
super proud of what you've done not just
what you've done but also who you've
become
thank you because you've changed a lot
thank you so much the last couple of
years for the better so
hey guys you heard it here first why not
get booked on
to the property investors crash course
i'll leave a link in the description
below
get booked on do it right now also don't
forget we've done
i've been doing a weekly winners on a
wednesday interview now for over two
years
so we've got a lot of these if you want
to be inspired and watch through the
interviews binge watch them
you can watch them right up here also if
you want to um
see more videos that might be helpful
you can check them out right here don't
forget to come on the crash course
and i look forward to seeing you guys
next time peace